je suis désolé qu'ils frère
désolé de t'avoir embarqué dans cette
histoire je voulais tout redevienne
comme avant
[Musique]
c'est mon frère où il tu peux m'aider ma
femme a besoin d'être opéré bienvenue
dans la vraie vie y a pas de justice
quand je pense que tu as risquer ta peau
pour ce pays tu as quitté ta famille ta
maison combien de temps 231 me
un peu plus attiré
32 millions je cherche un gars en plus
je voulais juste emprunté de l'argent
est-ce que j'étais déjà embarqué dans un
truc impossible là tu as l'occasion de
faire quelque chose pour ta famille
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous on
est en plein transfert de fonds plus
offre dans la nuit et j'aimerais bien
pas trop tarder j'ai bientôt fini mon
service je craquerais pas la banque
promis sur la banlieue ça ferait tâche
sur mon cv créé il fait bon ok
[Musique]
allez on se marre vous allez avoir une
super histoire contée hâte après soir
sur les flics
huit minutes
en boucle toute la zone
y'a rien qui sort
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous voulez prendre telle
endurance qu'il ya un faible et c'est
que j'amène à l'hôpital eh bien nous
aider on a besoin de votre aide comprend
des otages maintenant
hors de question de foncer sur cette
ambulance
on a un collègue dedans vous avez une
expérience de secouristes pris aux deux
blessés le coeur vous êtes militaire oui
on fait tout pour vous sauver
tu
un
pas de plus et je tire
oh
avec les travaux prenait pour un gros
tiers calme toi tu as dit
au revoir ma femme et mon fils va te
faire mais c'est que vous êtes braqueur
de banques
on n'est pas des missions
juste rentrer chez nous ce soir
machabée s'en sortir
on sait tous très bien quand vous êtes
dangereux sans blague
dites à vos hélico tous pareils
je vais être amené à la maison petit
frère il fait tous me ramener à la
maison
il
en outre lui même